du hast noch 13 kohle insgesamt in den
drei teilen übrigens schon wieder in
einer neuen folge
was haltet ihr von dem let's play offs
mit laden sie zu viel hoch und so weiter
denke ich mal damit von sektors danke
sektor standen kann sein dass sie das so
richtig megamäßig schon fast in einer
session aufnehmen also nein nicht ganz
wenn es extrem im voraus auf häufiger
geben ganz kurzformel down voll machen
die nehmen das quasi in ein zwei wochen
auf nein einfach wie eine tv-serie
hochzuladen ja glaube ich ja okay das
letzte keinen bock drauf haben oder so
eigentlich macht es keinen sinn aber
wenn sie gerade drauf potro andy du hast
ihn wieder angemacht
ich weiß ich versicherte von den findet
führt diese machen die laden halt extrem
viel und auch im eigentlich gar nicht
abonnieren weil die ganze box voll
gesperrt es kann immer nur den kanal
gehen und dann einzeln videos abrufen
ich finde auch den übrigens geil de
navidad presse als update oder dvi habe
ich kenne ich ihn jetzt amerikanische
englische akzent
ja und amerikanisch ist viel dover als
englischer amerikas voll geil ist ein
bruder jetzt da nicht alle stände von
new york dass briggs ich habe heute
nicht eingeworfen bistum essen
nein aber unsere geteilt haben dürfte
immer mal fällig sein
einer müsste knapp nahm ich hatte ein
paar knochen einzige stoppen
es blitzt ein konkreter was machen wir
wenn das jetzt hier noch nicht fertig
ist nach diesen vier folgen seite hält
nur eine folge länger zu wirst oder
importe aus china ist ja dann leider so
leider also finde es nicht gut wenn wir
da sind angeschlagen
ich finde das schade kalkulieren könnt
also komm nach haus an und eure häuser
genauso als wenn du jetzt nutella hier
mit frischkäse vergleich ist einfach
schrecklich das kann man nicht das ist
doch kann man kann man philadelphia hat
gebracht die sie als frisch verkauft
also kann man mit frischluft hier auf
dem server
dicke luft das kommt von schlecht luft
vom 14
also wäre ja was als mieter also ich
finds geil bei ihm das ja eigentlich
kann man nicht abonnieren
dann kommt ja der top box voll ist und
dann werden andere applaus nicht mehr
angezeigt aber ich finds allgemein das
ziemlich geil dass sie das durchhalten
mit den ganzen ablauf zwar teilweise so
10 18 11 12 videos pro tag
und alle wirklich alle ja und die
wirklich alle zur selben zeit eine
minecraft folge irgendwie nahm das und
abends zwei pro tag und die kriegen weiß
hier auf den klicks das ist unglaublich
das ist gut so aha
ok ich hab' fotoladen gemacht aber ja da
hast du eigentlich jede drohung oder was
bringst du erstmal krieger mein haus ein
stück als diese mit leni oft gar nicht
so gelaufen das warum auf einmal so hey
du gar das ist dir oder ich so bitte wer
wer ist das wie ein duales kettner das
ist ja unglaublich schwere gala.de
eltern einen offenen augen durch die
welt
ich kannte nur weil partie und wir haben
ein paar kann ja auch schon da ist weil
der typ der den an so ein bild
gezeichnet hat ja erklären die
öffentlichen weg ich meine gala vor sich
hat niemand von gut tiger willst es gar
nicht dass du jemanden bezeichnet aber
du wirst in meinem video aber niemand
weiß wer du bist
ich schreibe alle elf darf bei da an da
konkreter ich weiß es ich keine hat
jetzt auch die habe ich auch in skype
ganz ganz böse
nein du könntest natürlich auch mal
produktiv sein das ist schon wirklich
was wieder baut das haus am see x-mal
zugehört und am ende der straße steht
ein kripo vor den us house denkbar die
stars explosion oder so das nicht gut
ich finde es sie nicht schon hier
brauchte stein
wie lange es schon regnet nicht mehr
alternativen aufspielen
ich habe in folge macht aber an jetzt
wieder angemacht regen man ach jetzt
plötzlich wollen und sollen diesen film
monster damals gab es keine umgedrehten
steps ich würd mal sagen wir machen
nennen
/ abstand vom meer ruhig dass plötzlich
ist er auf den linken fuß runter wenn du
so vom haus fertig ist hat eine
vorstände getreideflächen wir haben habe
ich gleich eine fos haus kommt darauf an
wie ein top- media noch zu gast ist denn
die haben noch genau sieben minuten
möglich quasi schnitt förderschulen weg
dahin machen wir auch einmal kann ihn
nicht irgendein carlos war schön wenn es
unseren standard erfüllen so etwas ihrem
gewissen wohnstandard und den da die
wärmelast waren erfüllen egal ob wir
hier sind und nicht ob du hier bist und
nicken
egal ob er wohl ich habe einmal 100 das
schön hier genügen alt sie ist so schön
hier in einen zunächst etwa 40 suchst du
jetzt nach links nein ich habe besuch
aufgebrochen weil ich kein essen gehabe
und schrecken würde auf der suche
so stehen lassen werden
was zuerst wie schnell ich habe auch
nichts zu essen habe zwei herzen
dauerhaft
also ich würde mal überlegen wie wobei
ich den dezenten farben ich kann das
jetzt mal zukleistern oder abgelenkt
jetzt erkennen dass sheen folgt mir
unser kirchenfürst welt nochmal das
thema was wir hatten ja etwas haben wir
schon besprochen hat irgendwie keine
truhe nicht damit keine den us kommandos
weg clown bettina darfst du nie benutzt
dann richtet ein
ich habe schon brot machen ich mache mir
zum brot das richtig das darf ich ja ich
mache nur die idee noch nicht entwickelt
sind dann habt ihr gar keinen verlust
mache ja wäre ihre zuschauer dieses
video hier gerade seht mache ich ja noch
die andere serie da in der alten
minecraft version und soll kann ich
sagen dass da die pfeile von skeletten
die waren so was von viel langsamer als
sie jetzt sind mittlerweile tanzen jetzt
eigentlich erklären was es geht weil ich
meine wir wissen jetzt noch nicht dabei
wäre es nach dem guck mal rechts warum
machst du was in der alten version
das mache ich ganz einfach weil ich auch
da spielen möchte und da mache ich dann
so ein hardcore let's play in welcher
version in der beta art und 5
wirklich neu aber hardcore ist sondern
ich noch geil dass ich zeig dir mal die
erste folge
die kommt dann jeden samstagabend
sonderfolge und dann alle 40 minuten ein
und das ist hardcore dem motto 'der was
weder scan bot ich habe einfach nur
normal dingens gespielt gestellt auf
normale schwerer waltraud habe ich sogar
und sonst ist es eigentlich ein
charakter ich hab's einfach mal so
hardcore display dass ich die serie lost
jetzt ein bisschen dunkeln ich kann ihr
keinen fackeltanz er wolle nicht ob ist
einfach lieber opa du es nicht dass der
weltuntergang
die mayas hat uns doch gewusst jetzt
gehen wir brauchen das sie wolle diese
müssen rechtzeitig fertig kriegen
ich glaube ihr müsst uns leider noch mal
irgendwann ein laden einfach dann gerade
einmal vier zwischendurch zeit und dann
kommen noch mal wieder um damit fertig
zu stellen
also alle jetzt nicht mehr wollen jetzt
aber nicht nur wieder noch ein halbes
jahr zu einer wieder ein speed quiz
machen ja schnell
ja wir haben eineinhalb minuten dieser
vorsicht fällige seite aufschlagen nicht
peter doohan ich sag's doch was sollen
so was dich zu mir das war nur ein
kleiner population ich laufe nicht so
ich hab nichts aufgenommen das war es ja
du hast du standest neben mir lass uns
aufgenommen
nein ich darüber soll ich hatte wirklich
ja ich habe eine wichtige frage jetzt ja
los welches adjektiv steckt etymologisch
im wort gymnasium klug b nackt c und d
jung nackt was hat ihn logisch richtig
an jetzt geschafft 15 30
logisch seither konnten
ich bin so gut woher hast du die ganzen
sachen aus meiner neuen lektüre
warum waren dass viele leute die
behaupten das team aus dem eck aktuellen
welt der wunder hilft
das war das versteht man warum war das
so viele leute behauptet haben dass es
aus einer neuen weltwunder ausgabe für
die kinder ist in der version weil es
darum ging dass sie ausgerechnet haben
wieviel diagramm von batman kostet als
ob natürlich kann ich bin in diesem land
viel unterwegs und nicht selten
beschleicht mich dabei das gefühl einer
gewissen minderheit anzugehören
nicht etwa weil ich aus mecklenburg
komme das ist ist nicht was dieses
minderheiten gefühl erzeugt es ist
vielmehr meine tiefe überzeugung dass
die freiheit das allerwichtigste im
zusammenleben ist und erst freiheit
unserer gesellschaft kultur substanz und
inhalt verleihen ist das irgendwie
sondern rede die für den
politikunterricht geschrieben hast oder
oder freiheits buch du wirst du einen
lappen muss der outback
ich habe jetzt auch lektüre
ich blätterte jetzt auch mal so ist aber
nicht kugler gefurzt das ist mein buch
meine lektüre meine freunde pass auf ich
würde echt sagen dass das wir einfach
unseren besuch zwar sie pausieren weil
wenn ihr dann einige tausend zuschauer
gehabt dann kommen wir wieder machen es
auf zu regnen was ist wirklich nur fünf
minuten gepäck
die folge ist jetzt aber auch vorbei
nördlichen abholen es bleiben noch nicht
auf geht's in die schlacht in die
schlacht die sehkraft verlieren an die
laufer junge mann armee nicht lauf lauf
ja wohl drauf da läuft auf dem motto auf
dem motto kleiner lauf lauf lauf lauf
lauf lauf lauf lauf laufe ich mit sagt
okay jetzt gerecht aber keine sachen
einem das hab ich auch nicht gemacht
gut dann würde ich sagen wir sehen uns
in der nächsten folge von der today show
wie immer wenn ihr das video gut handelt
dann bewertet es wird mit einem
hoch wenn ihr es nicht so gut fand dann
bewertet es mit einem daumen runter
schreibt uns themen in die kommentare
seit den us teil in die kommentare nein
lass das einfach schreibt pogue job
mediaphor wenn in die kommentare
lenovo sind einfach in den raum nach der
seinen spruch machen was meine deine
sachen ich hab nicht auch so habe es
aufgenommen
eine spitzhacke dass aldi in die tore
getan eigentlich nein wenn schweizer
fehlt ok dann deine spitzhacke opfer
lagen hier liegt hier bringen sie dir
bin so nett aber liegt vor deiner tür in
der tür drin sogar mit 1000 folgen die
wir gemacht haben irgendwas an eurem
haus gebaut ja es ist fertig
was wie ein sie aus wie ein ic abteil
oder so nicht sagen ich hab selber nicht
mehr passau ist vorbei die folgesätze
vorbei eigentlich das heißt nährwert
beim nächsten mal